the continuing build-up at Cameron Bay
promises to make this port one of the
largest and busiest in the world port
construction at the bay did not actually
begin until June of 1965 three months
after a coastal survey determined its
potential as a major Harbor
soon after men of the 35th engineering
group which began initial construction
were joined by ordnance headquarters
quartermaster and transportation units
by November of last year the
quartermaster Depot was activated and
began accepting requisitions from
Qingyuan Natron and Saigon today a data
processing facility is nearing
completion which will enable much more
efficient inventory control another
important project currently underway by
the 87th engineers is the building of a
new causeway to the ammunition dump
in anticipation of the build-up yet to
come more construction equipment has
been concentrated at Cam Ranh Bay than
there has ever been anywhere else in
Southeast Asia
during August military civic action
programs were in full swing throughout
Vietnam several activities took place in
the province of phu yen a medical team
arrives at two aguar a village 360
kilometers northeast of saigon patients
are treated and supplied with medicine
instructions for its youths are usually
given in sign language when necessary
injections help underfed youngsters
fight off native ill bad teeth are a
recurrent problem many must be told
toothbrushes disinfectants medical
literature and clothing are handed out
this is all part of our program of
teaching personal hygiene the team stays
in the village until the last patient
has been treated only then do they
return to base not far away are the
headquarters of the 1st Brigade 101st
division on 27 August fire breaks out in
the village across from the base a
bucket squad is quickly organized by the
military police and additional
firefighting equipment is supplied by an
engineering company water arrives in
tank cars and soon the villagers help by
the American soldiers have the fire
under control
24 huts are burned to the ground and 28
families lose everything they own except
the clothes on their back still no lives
are lost and thanks to quick action by
the MPs and engineers most of the
village is saved no chances are taken on
the fire breaking out again the wreckage
is cleared away and every ember is
thoroughly drenched with water as the
last spark goes out our men go back to
their camp and the villagers begin to
rebuild
only a few kilometers away is the hamlet
of war adhesive here a school formerly
used as a headquarters by BC terrorists
is repaired on the roof volunteers from
the 101st airborne helped the workers
and protect them against possible sniper
fire
these holes have been made by grenades
while small arms fire has caused most of
the damage to the walls and the windows
as the children watch the work continues
roof tiles are put into place outside
our men stand guard while inside desks
are repaired and the classroom is put
back in order
helping whenever they can members of the
101st Airborne Division are doing their
share in the Civic Action Program
efforts by the 300 men headquarters
Australian force to aid the Vietnamese
people are gaining support the unit
recently began to help a small orphanage
in Saigon and when word of their
activities reached Australia companies
and individuals generously began to send
needed supplies of food and clothing on
September 3rd members of the unit
arrived at the orphanage to deliver the
latest shipment cartons of baby food and
sugar the orphaned children ranged from
only a few days old to three years of
age many formerly suffered from
malnutrition and body sores but now
Australian medical officer Captain John
Raftery
and a Vietnamese doctor have begun
regular medical visit
in addition to their direct benefits
civic action programs such as this are
playing an increasingly important role
in combating Vietcong propaganda
45 generals gathered in Seoul on August
13th for the commanding generals 4th
Invitational shooting match the 5 event
program between general officers and
Colonels of the Republic of Korea and US
Army's was held at the picturesque
Korean military academy range bordered
by pine studded slope team positions on
the morning long card are decided by lot
host for the match was Gerald whitey
beech commander of the 8th US Army at
last year's meet the first ROK army
walked off with a top prize in the
star-studded field which has been
dominated annually by Koreans and their
firearms teams take their places at the
firing line for the three rifle events
the carbine M 1 and M 14 the last two
events were shot with 38 and 45 caliber
pistols at a distance of 25 yards it was
their accuracy with these sidearms that
brought the second ROK army to the
forefront beating out general Beach's
8th army headquarters team 345 to 335
after tabulation of the scores and a
break for lunch
general beech presented the individual
award m to lieutenant general jung-hwan
park commanding general and captain of
the 2nd ROK army the team plaque for the
winning entry
at Lake kimse Germany a skydiving team
from the third support Brigade known as
the sky Eagles is about to give a water
landing jump exhibition before boarding
their h-34 helicopter members of the
jump team are checked out by First
Sergeant William Richey Headquarters
Company 35th supply service
this is how the lake resort located 40
miles south of Munich looks on a clear
September day the sky Eagles will soon
be joining the sailing craft in the lake
first man out is Sergeant Richie
parachuting into water is not easy
because it is unusually difficult to
judge the distance and speed at which
the jumper is falling he is followed by
first lieutenant George Sobel of the
seven hundred ninety third MP battalion
who free Falls for an interminable time
before pulling the ripcord
but the sky eagles know their job
without exception they land on target
wet but happy with their success
we're in Dorf Germany 6 September a US
team from Fort Sam Houston Texas is
representing the Armed Forces of the
United States in the annual console
international do sport militare sysm
modern pentathlon championships
this year's meet is being hosted by West
Germany cracked military teams from 10
European countries and the United States
are competing in the 5 event
championships which include horseback
riding
fencing pistol shooting swimming and a
4000 meter cross-country run each
competitor must complete all five events
before he can qualify for individual and
team standing the 5,000 meter
steeplechase course has 30 jumps taking
the hurdles is specialist William
Matheson of the US team despite a clean
ride an 11 second penalty relegates him
to 16th place in this event interest in
the system meat has been high since
modern pentathlon made its official
debut during the 1912 Olympics at that
time General George S Patton then
lieutenant finished fifth overall in the
individual standing fencing is conducted
under international rules using
electrical contact controls each man
must first compete against each member
of his own team before being matched
against members of other teams in this
event specialist Matheson leads the u.s.
contingent as he placed eighth among the
26 competitors for the pistol shoot
lieutenant Donald wall I'm and alternate
blackens his sights and discuss a
strategy with a team manager Lieutenant
Colonel
Emmett C Townsend in this event on the
25 meter pistol range specialist
Matheson comes through again to take
third place in the scoring swimming
events occupy the fourth day of the
competition
in the 300 meter swim Lieutenant James
coots cuts through the water to a fast
paced win for the US team
lieutenant coots proudly takes his place
of honor on the winter stand the final
event of the meet the 4000 meter
cross-country run gets underway for the
US with lieutenant who's running against
the clock specialist Larson number 8
gets his top off and starts down the
long trail specialist Matheson is the
third and last member of the team to
leave
the courses laid out over rugged and
buried terrain
specialist Larson with a time of 12 40.7
takes first place on the winners stand
specialist Larson proudly accepts his
prize on behalf of the US team then
stands at attention as the American flag
is raised signifying a first-place
victory in the event at formal
ceremonies held in the streets of Warren
door
the US team is awarded second place
behind Italy in the overall competition
at two-week intervals throughout the
year the advanced individual training
Brigade AIT Fort Dix New Jersey holds an
orientation on the weapons of the
infantry designed to give new recruits
and introduction to the weapons and
their capabilities the demonstrations
are popular with the public who turnout
in large numbers to see the show
among the weapons demonstrated is the
caliber 45 pistol the m14 a2 equipped
with an automatic capability bipod legs
two hand grips and a flash compensator
this weapon replaces the var the m16
rifle is gaining popularity among troops
in Vietnam it permits the launching of
grenades without supplementary
attachments
the m79 grenade launcher firing a 40
millimeter projectile is known as the
infantryman's hip pocket artillery the
m79 is designed to furnish the squad
with grenade protection between the
maximum distance a man can throw a
grenade and the minimum Rangers a mortar
can be fired the m60 machine gun has a
cyclic rate of fire of 550 rounds per
minute
and with its quick change barrel offers
a great advantage over the old caliber
30 machine gun
the m60 can be hand-held mounted on a
bipod or tripod the 50 caliber machine
gun has a semi as well as full automatic
capability when equipped with a
telescopic sight it may be used as a
sniper weapon the 90 millimeter
recoilless rifle replaces the 3.5
rocket-launcher as an anti-tank weapon
upon impact the round burns its way
through the tank hull and the molten
metal then ricochets killing the crew it
can be fired from the monopod or from
the shoulder the 106 millimeter
recoilless rifle is the company's long
range anti-tank weapon the 81-millimeter
mortar is a widely used weapon and is
normally placed in support of the rifle
company
for spectators and recruits alight a
good show